sony's increasing the price of the ps5
in some regions but nintendo is firm
that it is not doing the same for the
switch despite a rumor amazon is
reportedly not buying ea and we get an
all-new trailer for wolong fallen
dynasty
sony has announced that it is increasing
the price of the playstation 5 in many
regions around the world due to global
economic issues but nintendo is firm
that is not following suit
speaking to eurogamer nintendo's
president said in a statement we will
determine our future pricing strategies
through careful and continued
deliberations and do not have any plans
to increase the trade price of its
hardware instead nintendo is decreasing
the size of the box that the nintendo
switch comes in to help with shipping
issues and in turn they'll be using 20
less cardboard which will help with the
company's bottom line by using fewer
materials now the oled model already
comes in a box that's 14 smaller than
the original og switch did now think of
all the cardboard that could have saved
with labo
microsoft on the other hand hasn't been
as firm and whether or not it'll
increase the price of xbox series
consoles and instead said it is
constantly evaluating its business to
offer our fans great gaming options
they do make it seem as though the price
hike is unlikely but they never also
flat out deny it either still xbox does
have the cheaper solution for its
consoles with a series s so inherently
there's more options for them in case
there is a shortage or a price hike for
something like the series x
earlier this morning a report suggested
that amazon was set to announce the
acquisition of electronic arts later
today however it did not take long for
that report to be denied ea has been the
subject of several rumors about being
acquired amidst major buyouts such as
microsoft acquiring bethesda then
activision blizzard as well as sony's
purchase of bungie and then embracer
group's buying spree of crystal dynamics
idos montreal and most recently the lord
of the rings property
after all ea is reportedly pursuing a
sale or merger and is said to have had
talks with disney apple comcast and of
course amazon but as of now there is no
official news to report on of the
behemoth developer publisher being
purchased at this time the speculation
for amazon to acquire ea isn't
completely without its merits after all
amazon has published a few games
including the short-lived crucible but
most recently new world they also have
their own cloud gaming service amazon
luna so
it
can make sense in related news embracer
groups deal to acquire crystal dynamics
idos montreal which also means the tomb
raider ip has been completed because why
not embrace your group is just buying
everything at this stage
including literally like a huge physical
library of games
i haven't even heard about these folks
until recently
now they just own everything or they're
trying they're attempting to own a lot
of things not everything
souls like fans have been eating well
recently because today we got an all-new
gameplay trailer for wolong fallen
dynasty which comes from the ninja
gaiden neo and strangers of paradise
developers team ninja the game will have
its first publicly playable demo at
tokyo game show which begins september
15th so be on the lookout for more
information then
speaking to ign the developers said the
game will not have a stamina gauge like
neo meaning it'll likely have an
emphasis on aggressive combat in
comparison to other entries in the souls
like genre
and before you go here's just a friendly
reminder that if you want to play
destiny 2 and all of its expansions for
free you have until august 30th to do so
so if you've been contemplating and
dipping your toes into that big old
sci-fi world now's your chance anyways
thanks for coming to us for news today
till next time i'm kurt this is gamespot
see you later